so today I want to tell you about the
pancake number which is among the most
ridiculously named numbers in maths but
it is technically to do with pancakes or
at least pancakes are one nice way to
explain what this number is we have a
pan full of pancakes here and the idea
where this is they're not all the same
size so have five different sizes of
pancake and we also have a very
inconsiderate chef who makes pancakes
all different sizes and then serve them
up in the wrong order because I'm sure
you'll agree if you've got a stack of
pancakes of all different sizes the most
satisfying way is to have them in
decreasing order of size with the
smallest one at the top and the biggest
one at the bottom so we need to try and
get this stack of pancakes back into
order so I stick out a plate I'll use my
pancake flipper yep so stick that on a
plate so the question now is how do we
put these pancakes back into the right
order there is a rule about how I'm
allowed to shuffle these around I'm
allowed to take the top section of
pancakes and turn it over and that's all
I can do so in this case and what do I
want to do I want to flip maybe the
whole thing yeah I want to flip the
whole thing no in fact first I'm gonna
flip these top two and the reason for
that will become apparent shortly so I
do that so that's one flip and I'm now
gonna flip the whole thing there we go
and now I'm gonna flip
I shouldn't have flipped the top two
I'll figure this out eventually so I
flip those three that's three flips and
now flip the whole thing again as four
flips
and if I hadn't flipped those top two at
the start I would have had not to do
this no but nevermind so that's five
flips which is fine because I know that
any stack of pancakes can be fixed in
five or fewer flips this one I suspect
could have been in slightly for your
five but in this case I've used exactly
five which is within the bound so that's
fine
so any stack of five pancakes can be
done in five or fewer flips there
obviously some that well this is
currently in the state where it needs a
row flips but they're obviously some
that can be done in fewer than five and
the most you'll need for five pancakes
doing it in the most efficient possible
way is five so the pancake number four
five pancakes is their four five and
this works for any number of pancakes in
a stack so I can show you what happens
with three pancakes there are
six possible orderings for three
pancakes so I could have small medium
large three at the bottom again but
instead have two and then one two at the
bottom then three then one like that one
at the bottom and then two and then
three two at the bottom one three like
that and finally one at the bottom three
and then two that gives me all six
possible orderings and for each one of
these I can work out how many flips I
need to get it back into the the sort of
standard correct way up so in this case
it's zero flips it's already there this
can be done in one which is just to flip
the whole thing this one can be done in
one flip this one if I flip those top
two and then flip the whole thing I'll
get back to sorting so I'm going to call
that one two flips this one if I flip
the whole thing and then flip those top
two around that'll be two flips and in
this case this is the most difficult one
because this can't be done in fewer than
three flips so I can do it in three and
I would maybe say flip the whole thing
and then you flip the top two and they
look the whole thing but it can't be
done in fewer than three so for three
pancakes the pancake number is three yes
it does look a little bit patently so
for three it's three for four it's four
for five it's five after that it starts
to go on so every so often it goes up by
two instead of going up by one so it's
not quite always just the number of
pancakes that you've got but it is
actually something that people try and
calculate they try and work out what is
the pancake number for a given number of
pancakes and it's actually an ongoing
question because for 20 pancakes we
don't know what the pancake number is no
no it's it's an open question in maths
we don't actually have 20 or above we
don't actually really know that what the
answer is to this and I guess it's
partly because it's just a massive
computation if you've got 20 pancakes in
a stack the number of possible ways you
could order 20 pancakes in a stack is
massive for any given ordering the
number of possible sets of flips you
could do it's even massive er you know
to check all of those and see which one
is the most efficient would take a lot
of computer time so no one's managed to
crack that yet for 19 it's 22 I think
something like that so yeah these we
know it's more than 22 and in fact we
know it's less than I think 35 and the
reason the person that we have to credit
with the the fact that we know it's less
than 35 is Bill Gates
so Bill Gates that the guy off of
Microsoft when he was at university in
1979 when he was 24 he did a paper
unfortunately the paper wasn't called
like on the pancake number it was called
something like algorithms for prefix
reversals because that's the the
technical computer science term for this
if you're taking the first section and
reversing it
that's a prefix reversal and his paper
they proved that there is an upper bound
for the pancake number four if you know
how many pancakes you've got what the
upper bound is for any pancakes so I
think for n pancakes they prove that
it's 5 n plus 5 over 3 which means that
for 20 pancakes it's 105 over 3 that
means it's 35 that is thanks to Bill
Gates since then they've actually worked
out a better upper bound for it that's
slightly nicer if they've now shown that
anything is less than 18 and over 11
which was found in 2009 which was
exactly 40 years later they managed to
improve on that bound so there is a way
that will always work for any given kind
of messed up stack of pancakes so the
trick is that you take whichever pancake
is the biggest pancake that's not
currently where it's supposed to be and
put it to the top and then I put that
one to where it's meant to be if you
keep repeating that so if now safe
pancake 3 wasn't in the right place you
do the same thing you put it to the top
and then each time you you're kind of
definitely gonna place at least one
pancake possibly more if you're lucky
you will always do it in 2 n minus 3 so
4n pancakes in the case of 5 it would
always do it in 7 or fewer but I know
that 4-5 pancakes the pancake number is
5 which means there is a way to do all
of them in five or fewer so that
wouldn't be necessarily the most
efficient method the nice thing about
this is he actually originated from like
a real world problem so there was a
mathematician Jacob Goodman who was
trying to solve a problem in the real
world and this thing occurred to him is
like oh that's an interesting puzzle you
know how can i how can i find how many
flips it takes to do this and he wasn't
actually using pancakes at the time it's
really unfortunate he wasn't in a
kitchen you know cooking pancakes and
discovered this he had a stack of towels
in the cupboard it was a really domestic
math problem and he had to try and put
these towels in the cupboard but he just
had a shelf and there wasn't any kind of
surface nearby and he needed to change
the order of the towels so he could just
take the top of the stack and flip it
over and he kind of was like actually
that's that's
nice problem and he wanted to write it
up for a magazine for american
mathematical monthly and he was like oh
how can i reframe this so that it's a
nice accessible thing and this idea of
using stacks of pancakes with a flipper
this is his way into this he used the
pseudonym he wrote an article under the
name of harried waiter which is harried
waiter who's carrying the pancakes and
so on and it was you know is a nice
little here's a problem and people
responded to it and wrote back and stuff
so that was how the the thing kind of
first originated but it's since it's
become like a real thing and people work
on it people publish papers on it so
there's a chap called David Cohen who
writes for The Simpsons who's a
mathematician a computer scientist in
his spare time when he's not writing for
The Simpsons I guess he trained as a
computer scientist and while he was
studying he also did a paper on this
which was on a thing called the burnt
pancake problem and in that case you've
got pancakes where one side of the
pancake is burnt and you want to end up
with them all in the right order in the
stack but also all the burnt sides down
so that no one can tell that you've
burnt all your pancakes on one side and
that makes it slightly more complex and
it means that you have to make sure that
you do all the the steps in the right
order and you might find that you've you
know you've done it right but they're
all upside down and you need to redo the
whole thing so that's another thing that
he's kind of published a paper on and
that's a separate but related problem I
guess you know I'm glad you watch your
videos here on YouTube but sometimes you
want to go a bit deeper than these
tempting nuggets of information we give
you and that's where the great courses
plus can come in these on-demand videos
can be entire lectures or entire courses
full of videos taught to you by leading
experts from around the world there's a
boat full of brilliant courses covering
all sorts of mathematical subjects of
course I've spoken about these before
I'm sure they'll appeal to numberphile
fans but it's not just mathematics you
name it and they'll cover it
sometimes when I'm just grazing on the
great courses Plus what I like to look
at is geology and geography things like
this whatever your little niche interest
you can go really deep here on the great
courses plus for a free one-month trial
go to the great courses plus.com slash
numberphile that's a free one-month
trial there's the address on the screen
the great courses plus comm slash
numberphile give them a look I'm sure
you'll like them and now thanks to them
for supporting this video
you